yeah peace i love peace i'd
be out of a job with peace
do we know each other
time
reality
it's changeable
where you want to be
that's the question isn't it. Every universe
is different each one
slow down a little bit there's a few people in
the room that don't understand not me i get it
who are you the name's captain carter
i am the watcher i observe all that transpires
here but i do not cannot will not interfere
i guess i have to freestyle then
we haveyou outnumbered. A ravager never flies solo
i said never flies solo is
that some kind of catchphrase
you had me wear it for a second
journey to face the unknown
and ponder the question
what if
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my brand
new marvel what if trailer video they just dropped
a brand new one with a whole bunch of footage
from all the episodes so we'll break it all down
and we finally have a release date i will be
doing full episode videos for it starting in
august when it releases so be sure to subscribe to
get everything if you're brand new to the channel
now you can see why they waited till after loki
to sort of do this series because it trades so
much more heavily on the multiverse trope and gets
way crazier than the loki series gets as crazy as
alligator loki is superior loki marvel's what if
because it's an animated series can just take the
concept of the multiverse and the marvel movies
to the nth degree and there's no real budgetary
constraints like even during the loki series they
had that bottle episode during episode three when
they were stuck on the planet lamentis one which
felt like a smaller episode because they spent so
much money on loki episode 5 and what's probably
going to be a really really crazy loki episode 6
finale the way kevin feige pitched the marvel what
if episodes is that each one is going to feel like
a big marvel movie but there are 10 episodes total
so it's way more episodes way more characters way
more movies that they're covering what i'll do
though is because there's so much stuff going on
during this i'll start at the beginning of the
trailer and work our way through shot by shot
talking about easter eggs wtf moments and number
these as we go along just to stay organized but
it starts with the footage from the first iron man
movie and it's tony stark but what if he got saved
by killmonger during the events of that first
movie so the idea during this episode whichever
one this winds up being is that killmonger forms
a partnership with tony stark because he owes him
his life and as you can see he's still wearing his
armor in a version of wakanda and he's charging
there's this big battle that he's part of as you
can also probably detect in the background the
watcher is speaking to a lot of different people
and you have this party version of thor that's
what they're calling this version of thor with
the sleeveless armor party thor he says slow down
some of the other people don't understand i
totally understand but some of these people don't
the whole idea is they're doing a version of what
you would consider the exiles in the mcu it's like
a multiverse version of avengers so you actually
see all the main characters on this big poster
here like you even see a version of spider-man
wearing doctor strange's cloak of levitation make
all the harry potter jokes you're a wizard now
peter nice call back to the time that spider-man
actually did wear a cape and to spider-man into
the spider verse spider-man doesn't wear a cape
and then they go down to his lair see a cape that
also feels like it's kind of foreshadowing the
events of doctor strange into the multiverse of
madness so the way they said that all the marvel
disney plus series are supposed to cross over with
and influence the marvel phase 4 movies some of
this is also foreshadowing the craziness of doctor
strange too multiverse of madness maybe a little
bit of spider-man no way home as well but probably
more in common with doctor strange multiverse of
madness like you have peggy carter captain britain
talking to a version of dark doctor strange who
goes way way darker during the events of the first
doctor strange movie but you also notice it does
sound like they got somebody different that's
not robert danny jr to voice iron man during
the series most of the mcu marvel movie actors
came back to do the voices of their animated
characters but obviously there's going to be like
one or two people that probably didn't come back
i believe the idea with the dark doctor strange
is that a version of christine palmer in his
universe winds up dying and he tries to use magic
to bring her back or find a way to bring her back
and it just goes completely off the rails and
drives him to a much darker place it's just kind
of the way they're pitching him you can even see
a version of him fighting the ancient one this
seems like a version of doctor strange from that
episode using the time stone to turn time back so
to speak like he's going back to the events of
him in the lambo before he has his accident but
actually talking about the multiverse you
see the events of the first avengers film
but then it sort of shifts realities and you get
that multiverse avengers team i'm not exactly sure
what they're going to call their team but it's
basically meant to be a multiverse avengers team
because of the way they're mirroring the
avengers assemble scene from that first movie
and it's peggy carter captain britain you
have a version of black panther but that's
actually supposed to be killmonger black panther
called king killmonger obviously he becomes king
of wakanda because you have a version of black
panther who became star-lord there's a version
of gamora wielding thanos's double-bladed sword
from avengers infinity war on avengers end game
she's also got a version of thanos armor as well
then you have that party version of thor without
the sleeves this is more of the guardians of the
galaxy episode with t'challa star-lord with him
stealing a version of the power stone michael
rooker coming back as yondu doing the voice over
talking to him about where he wants to be it seems
like a lot of that episode deals with them going
to see the collector as well like they have that
giant fight where they're fighting a really really
ripped version of the collector like you see him
with this shirt off maybe they're just trying to
redeem the character a little bit in marvel comics
the collector is one of the elders of the universe
he's very very powerful there's a version of the
hulk with black widow it's not clear which movie
this is happening during but then it seems like
the hulk is smashing a bunch of ultron's robots
there's also a lot of ultron footage during this
as well when they jump to the next voiceover
actor talking more about the multiverse sort of
continuing picking up that conversation in the
trailer the voice actually sounds like it's coming
from vision but it doesn't sound like paul bettany
unless the way they sync the voice up with
vision's lips is meant to be misleading it just
sounds like they're trying to say that somebody
else winds up becoming a version of vision you
see party thor in what seems like vegas fighting
a bunch of ultron's robots i guess that kind of
explains the party thor theme i'm sure thor would
love to go to vegas if he could then you have a
version of loki that seems like it's from the
events of the first thor film but he's brought
the asgardian army which he's in control of now
with the warriors three behind him and the cask
of ancient winters with odin's spear and it seems
like he just opens up with the cask of ancient
winters on nick fury and shield you also see
more footage of him later in the trailer marching
the asgardian army into the united nations so it
almost seems like he's trying to conquer earth but
it's happening during the events of the first thor
film we get more howard the duck he's also during
that guardians of the galaxy t'challa star-lord
episode and if you notice the three-piece suit
that he's wearing that's actually straight out
of the comics then this is a version of captain
carter hopping on the iron man skinny steve rogers
in the very tank-like world war ii iron man suit
going off into battle so eventually she winds
up fighting a version of red skull there's also
another really cool scene of her wielding what
seems like a version of excalibur which is used by
captain britain in the comics this is more footage
of killmonger like even in this footage over here
you see the dorma lager with the version of pepper
potts fighting together and you have shuri here in
the foreground but it also seems like some of this
dora melange footage later in the trailer is of
them fighting a version of scarlet witch who seems
like maybe she's gone full team ultron during
the events of the original avengers age of ultron
movie like it might actually be that killmonger is
helping protect wakanda and it's ultron's robots
attacking wakanda with the help of scarlet witch
trying to take their vibranium there's a couple
different scenes of captain carter here her just
attacking more nazis during the events of world
war ii during that first captain america movie the
reason why there's so much footage of her during
this is because i believe she's going to lead that
multiverse avengers team but also because she is
the first episode of the series like it'll be what
if captain america for the first episode and i
don't know if they're going to drop the first
two episodes that first week or if it'll just
be the first episode they usually wait to the
very last minute before they explain all those
really specific plans all the stuff that you
would want to know there's a version of arnhem
zola also from that first captain america movie
it's hard to tell where this is happening it could
either be on ego the living planet because he does
show up later in the trailer or it could be from
the really dark dr strange episode you see the
watcher amidst the new york city landscape just
talking about his mission about how he cannot
interfere with human affairs he is bound to just
watch everything play out there's a version of
the ravagers led by t'challa star-lord you have
korath in the background yondu next to him i'm
not sure who's on his right but then you have
taserface on the far right then we get a version
of peter parker spider-man from what seems like
either the events of spider-man homecoming or
captain america civil war he seems a little
bit older than he was during captain america
civil war so i will assume that this is from the
events of spider-man homecoming or at some point
after the events of that film but this answers
all your questions about whether or not they
can use spider-man during these episodes so just
charting the timeline it just seems like it takes
place before the events of spider-man far from
home before he upgrades to the steve ditko suit
this is a version of black widow on the motorcycle
probably from the events of avengers age of ultron
it seems like a lot of this footage happens with
them fighting a version of ultron this is from
the marvel zombies episode you see zombie captain
america then you see a version of zombie iron man
in his armor from what seems like avengers
infinity war this seems like a version of zombie
coal obsidian behind him so it just sounds like
whatever happens during this version of avengers
infinity war it leads to the creation of all these
zombies like something goes really really wrong
this is more of hawkeye and thor from the events
of that first thor movie they have to have a way
of explaining the party version of thor though
so this version of thor could wind up becoming
the party thor we see ego the living planet who
i guess in this version of events in whatever
multiverse t'challa star-lord comes from is his
father instead of being peter quill's father
this footage of captain britain with excalibur
fighting this giant tentacle monster seems like
it's after she's met with doctor strange and it's
coming from one of those big crossover episodes it
could be schumagorth it could be just any other
random creature from the multiverse there's a
version of drax with t'challa's star-lord during
the events of that guardians of the galaxy episode
black widow but here's the difference during
this episode it seems like she's wielding captain
america's shield except it has a very different
looking star on it it actually seems much more
like a russian themed captain america shield like
the red star of russia on it this is just more of
killmonger from the events of that first iron
man film after he saved tony stark then you get
all of ultron's robots taking off in mass like i
said it might wind up being killmonger and tony
stark iron man saving wakanda and that's how he
winds up becoming a version of king killmonger
t'challa's mother leading the door milaje into
battle just like you see all the other wakanda
big fight scenes a version of vision ripping the
mind stone out of his own forehead that might be
during the avengers infinity war episode a version
of bruce banner hulking out the weird thing about
the head in the jar here is this is actually
supposed to be scott lang ant-man not sure why he
is ahead in the jar but because vision's standing
next to him that might be from the events of the
avengers infinity war episode or it could be from
the avengers age of ultron episode then they have
that funny scene of t'challa star-lord trying to
escape with all of thanos or ronan's men during
the events of the first guardians of the galaxy
movie with yondu saving him with his fin arrow
and if you weren't sure what was going on here
this is chadwick boseman doing the voice of
his character they actually recorded all of his
dialogue a long time ago before he passed away
so i'm sure when they introduced the character
there'll be a special memorial dedicated to
him during that episode like thought of some
special card saying in memory of chadwick boseman
they've actually already started filming the live
action black panther 2 movie and there have even
been more confirmations about namor in a big
battle between wakanda and atlantis so we'll do
more separate videos about that when we get more
information about the black panther 2 movie then
you see the broken mirror depicting many episodes
many alternate realities from the marvel movies so
starting top to bottom left to right obviously
there's like a whole bunch of footage in here this
might be from the guardians of the galaxy episode
then you have loki going to the united nations in
what seems like the same episode from the events
of the first thor movie after he's taken out nick
fury with the cask of ancient winters then thor
trying to take his hammer back for the first time
skinny boy steve rogers t'challa star-lord then
you have the hulk in the middle of hooking out
the hydra logo and more of captain carter getting
the super soldier serum becoming captain britain
this just seems like one of the dora milaje this
monastery seems like it's from the first captain
america movie this seems like it's from the
dark doctor strange episode captain america
shield in the ice leading into the events of the
first avengers film this is proxima midnight from
that avengers infinity war episode this is more of
killmonger from that first iron man movie episode
yondu from the guardians episode then red
skull also from that captain carter captain
britain episode yondu and the ravagers picking up
young t'challa star-lord as a child iron man then
in the donut scene from iron man 2 that also seems
like it's connected to the killmonger footage of
them forming their partnership then the mirror
fractures again breaking into even more different
realities depicting more scenes so again top to
bottom left to right this is howard stark giving
peggy carter to the super soldier serum more
of the guardians episode than iron man with an
arc reactor in his chest not sure which episode
this comes from this is from that doctor strange
episode when he first comes to comartaj to ask
the ancient one for help this old man seems like
t'challa's father king t'chaka this is black
panther but this might be king killmonger black
panther then more captain britain and then this
is just loki next to her from that loki episode
the zombie with blonde hair and regular colored
shirt not really sure who that's supposed to be
this is young t'challa from the guardians of the
galaxy episode it's not clear who the woman with
the scratch marks on her face is but it kind of
looks like jane foster then bald obadiah stain
then as the watcher asks them to dare and face the
unknown and ask the question what if the mirror
shatters again into more alternate realities kind
of swirling into the montage in the background of
infinite possibilities then the shards form into
the logo title and they reveal the release date
for episode 1 is august 11th which is wednesday
like i said what'll probably wind up happening
is they'll drop more trailer footage during
the olympics just because so many eyeballs
will be on that so we won't have to wait that
long after the loki finale before we get the
next big marvel disney plus series so this will be
the next big thing that i'll be doing videos for
they also end this with the new version
the disney plus logo but it's yondu's arrow
completing the logo the other brand new stuff
that we see during the poster here too like we
see gamora wearing thanos armor i already talked
about spider-man wearing doctor strange's cloak
of levitation this is black widow in the upper
right this is a version of ultron with all six
infinity stones in his chest like he himself has
become a living infinity gauntlet but everyone
let me know in the comments if you spotted any big
easter eggs during this footage any big multiverse
easter eggs that i didn't talk about during
the video there's going to be a bunch of stuff
happening during this it'll be way crazier than
the loki episodes like i said i just love the idea
marvel was like oh you like alligator loki and you
thought that was crazy we'll hold our beer we'll
do you one better but what'll happen is i have
some loki bonus videos that i'm working on also
the black widow movie is being released tomorrow
as i'm posting this video so i will do a black
widow post credit scene video and some easter
egg videos for that as well while you wait for
everything everyone click here for my full loki
episode 5 video and click here for all my other
loki episode videos thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!